this community needs to know that we
support them in its entirety
addressing asian hate today governor
steve sisolak and state leaders joined
forces
to show support and call for an end to
violence against
the asian community across the nation
good afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here at four o'clock i'm
christian casadis and i'm brian loftis
kirsten is off today
now crowds of people did gather at the
chinatown plaza over on spring mountain
road this afternoon
along with the governor and other
representatives reporter kate houston
now joins us there live with more
kate yes the core message today was to
end
all violence against the asian community
now this rally
comes after the mass shooting in atlanta
that killed six women of asian descent
as well as the various attacks across
the san francisco bay area
now today more than 100 people gathered
carrying signs with messages saying
love conquers hate we need peace and
stop
asian hate representatives from various
community groups were here
as well as congresswoman dina titus
governor steve sisilak
and first lady kathy sisilak many spoke
about the importance of education when
it comes to ending discrimination
as well as the importance of reporting
these crimes when they happen
unfortunately this community for a
couple of reasons one the language
barrier they don't often report things
so a lot of crimes against the community
go unreported and two that they just
kind of don't want to
quote unquote rock the boat but they
need to they help the need to make us
aware
they've got our support you saw
congresswoman titus here with us
metro's supporting us so we're doing
everything to make sure that everyone in
this community
is in everyone in nevada feels safe
to further that effort congresswoman
dina titus says she's working to pass a
law to enhance penalties for hate crimes
against asian americans titus represents
district one which includes this area of
spring mountain road
she says the asian pacific community is
the fastest growing group
in her district now this rally did
follow a round table discussion
where local authorities and law
enforcement denounced the
uptick in violence and said it needs to
stop they're now asking the community to
come forward
and report these crimes when they're
happening reporting live from spring
mountain in valley view kate houston 8
news now